la personne que je représente à une
offre à vous faire
chaque mort tu dois valeur d'un accident
c'est votre spécialité me
je ne fais plus ce genre de choses
j'ai attendu trop longtemps pour avoir
ma revanche 36' toutes les cibles de
cette liste
aucun signe d' intrusion
c'est parce qu'elle est assis devant moi
dans la salle du coffre connard
j'ai passé ma vie à organiser la mort
des gens toi je veux organiser sa vie
là je vais vous trouver une issue à quoi
vous pensez vous avez mourir j'aurais
jamais cru que mourir était aussi fort
il ne s'arrête jamais
moi
budget
disponible
peter klein
nos deux escales
m
donc
à cette fin
plein de saletés sont au
oui